[Music]
hey everyone is Peter Brown standing in
for freelance reviewer Nathan Didem Pro
Evolution Soccer 2017 has arrived and
the good news is that it is a genuine
step forward for the series yes there
are signs here that PES is rivalry with
FIFA has led to an unnecessary
overextension in features and modes but
the core of PES 2017 the soccer it plays
is competitive once again welcome to all
we will be on the way very shortly once
all the pleasantries are complete the
improvements this year are a mixture of
the specific and the general goalkeepers
are a good example of the former
offering more realistic defense against
corners and savable shots and a dynamic
set of new animations that helped give
PES the kind of authenticity this series
often lacked there are also big
improvements to ball control turning and
the time it takes for players to recover
after physical contact these add up to a
sharper more agile game and collectively
contribute to the otherwise hard to pin
down feeling that PES 2017 has improved
all over more specifically this year the
skill dribbling action comes into its
own PES has a pretty deep set of skills
buried in its control system but it's
intricate to the point that learning
more than one or two show pieces is
beyond most players in PES 2017 the
tight control dribbling activated offers
a rough equivalent to FIFA skill system
an accessible way to trick defenders
open up space and create unexpected
angles one more particularly prominent
element of PES improvements this year is
the fluidity of attacking play through
balls and crosses have a high success
rate and always feel dangerous crosses
to feel more user-friendly
wonderful quick face dramatic
aesthetically pleasing arcs can be
produced on the run from deep outside
the box or under pressure from opposing
players making flowing edge of the seat
matches not just possible but common
[Applause]
if playing with the ball is taken to
strive forward defending this year is
more of a qualified success one-on-one
defending out wide is fine but in
congested mid fields as the ball
approaches the Box defending can become
clumsy and haphazard ai-controlled
teammates sometimes double up on the
opposing player with the ball ignoring
simple interceptions during scrambles
for possession or simply getting in each
other's way
if the joy and intensity of attacking in
this year's game is excellent the
defending struggles to keep up
[Applause]
[Music]
and away from its core gameplay PES 17
struggles in recent years the value of
real names grounds and the rest is
higher than ever this is a thing
peculiar to our age a time of intense
media management brand partnerships and
constant streams of social media
interaction soccer is everywhere all the
time and a sniff of inauthentic means
death in the slick transaction between
sport and consumer yes it's possible to
download and tinker with option files to
improve the in-game presentation and yes
Master League still the game's best mode
is like a refuge from the branded
assault of modern stalker and escape
into an unlicensed parallel world but
PES 17s focus isn't on Master League
it's on my club the ultimate team style
squad builder that is in base terms like
Master League but with microtransactions
unfortunately PES is licensing
shortfalls make my club a difficult sell
even with improvements on last year's
presentation including a concise
introductory tutorial and clearly laid
out panel menus there's a hollowness to
the mode that leaves it feeling like an
off-brand alternative not helping in
this regard is PES is continued
inconsistency online the ultimate goal
of my club is to take your team of
gleaming stars and pit them against
online opposition either in one-off
games or in the mini league divisions
mode but online play suffers from
serious connectivity issues wait times
for opponents are lengthy and most games
I played suffer from a latency that left
a full half second between me pressing a
button and my player releasing a pass or
shot essentially unplayable in a game
built on anticipation and timing I had a
good connection roughly the same number
of times I was disconnected entirely
heavy lag was the standard
all of which leaves PES 17 feeling like
a superbly talented team of footballers
playing on a terrible uneven pitch if
your football game of choice compliments
your love of the real world sport or
you're interested in testing yourself
against online all-comers consider
yourself warned if you're unlikely to
play online and don't mind tinkering for
an hour or so to get your leagues
looking unofficially official PES is
once more a serious contender
[Music]
you